did a corporation and slavery did the
government do it what the slavery have
to do with what we're talking about
we're saying we're saying there is a
role for government in our society and
incorporation I do but slavery was wrong
to begin with so let's not even it was
government that created government is
there to protect property life liberty
and that's it I mean you mentioned
Walmart so what are you afraid that
Walmart's gonna do to you what am i
afraid that what does walmart do go and
ask the employees that are working in
sweatshop type conditions that don't
have health care how is it then why
don't they quit I mean Walmart doesn't
hold a gun to their head if they can get
a better job so why did the rape victim
get raped who was she doing out late at
night there's been memorials for Steve
Jobs all over the place at every Apple
store every every there's reporters that
are all around the world that never
asked one single question to Steve Jobs
when he was alive
why are you manufacturing your iPhone in
China and you don't have any your
manufacturing can I tell you why because
we've made it fair to the American
people big weight the American people
don't own those dogs Steve Jobs has the
right to manufacture where he wants he
does right to you and the problem is we
have made it too expensive for him the
manufacturer weekly the government
workers and want too much so the
government put too much oh it's think
again remember the reason that content
that employer employers write wanna
lower wages is because their customers
want low prices
everybody in this park wants low prices
you can't have low prices we don't know
do you believe that the federal
government has a right to exist in to
govern the lives if it has the right to
exist but not in the form it exists
today it's it's operating outside
believes the EPA should be disbanded I
think it does a lot more harm than good
do you believe the SBA should be dead
I'd like to get rid of it what about the
FDA huh
the board I think the Board of Education
we should I want about the Board of
Education I want to get rid of the
entire federal department education yeah
it is wasting our money then it is
running up the cost of Education sure
what I've learned let me
what I've learned over the years is to
never argue with a fool and you my
friend or a fool
okay so all right cool right so I just
stumbled into all my wealth I run all
these how did you say how did you
disband the EPA education can I call you
crazy I call you an idiot all right